[Música]
sale un tenderete américa de france 24
hoy lunes se acompaña en nuestro estudio
de nuestra mesa como siempre más romeros
a la mar volvemos a hablar de las
vacunas contra el coi 19 porque
recordemos que esta pandemia no se ha
ido esta vez para los niños pequeños los
menores de 5 años
buenos días raúl efectivamente de vez en
cuando tenemos que volver a estos los
ratones para ir para ir informando
recordemos que la semana pasada vamos la
noticia de que en eeuu anna privado
aprobado las vacunas tanto de modernas
como de spicer para los niños menores de
5 años algo que abre la puerta a que se
haga en otros lugares del mundo sin
embargo también ha despertado pues
muchas inquietudes muchas preguntas para
los padres de adultos responsables de
estos menores de cinco años así que
vamos a resolver estas dudas con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia un lunes más doctor muy
buenos días y gracias por acompañarnos
los datos que mostraban en eeuu es que
la eficacia de estas vacunas puede ser
bastante menor en estos rangos de edades
que en los adultos siendo así porque
valdría la pena vacunar este rango de
edad a estos niños menores de 5 años
lo primero que hay que aclarar es que
los estudios hay dos tipos de uno de
picasso y otro de efectividad lo que
muestra es que la vacuna es efectiva es
decir que genera defensas y la eficacia
se va a medir con los desenlaces de
evitar enfermedades graves o enfermas o
complicaciones los estudios de eficacia
son los que están en digamos son godín
están en camino y los estudios de
felicidad muestran que si hay una
respuesta inmune acá esa respuesta
inmune como los niños no tienen
enfermedad tan grave pues digamos que
los desenlaces son diferentes a los que
salvan las vacunas de resaltos pero son
seguras son efectivas y vamos a mirar
qué tan eficientes son cuando se hagan
los estudios en vida real sí y
precisamente sobre eso quiero andar el
doctor muy buena mañana del lunes como
éste explique entonces que esta vacuna
sean menos eficaces en estas edades
si raúl lo que estamos viendo es que
como no hay el desenlace que se
enfermedad grave los niños en algunos si
lo hace pero en otros niños no lo hacen
la gran mayoría pues entonces ese
desenlace enfermedad graves digamos no
es lo que sigue el parámetro que es
importante en un niño las complicaciones
en la respuesta inflamatoria post coito
y además de eso lo que sabemos hoy de la
hepatitis es hepatitis que pensamos que
era por un adenovirus al parecer la
información muestra es que es por un
coach persistente en el tiempo que hace
que los niños y algunos niños pueden
desarrollar una hepatitis que en
ocasiones puede ser fulminante esas son
las razones para seguir vacunando niños
y que debemos ampliar la vacunación en
ellos sí por supuesto además también
pues todos esos niños menores de 5 años
que también tienen condiciones de salud
preexistentes que deberían a ser
protegidos pero ahora hablemos más en
general de toda la población en general
qué sentido epidemiológico puede tener
también que todo este rango de edad de
niños estén vacunados no a nivel general
de inmunidad poblacional
claro recordemos que uno de los
problemas es cuando hay susceptibilidad
hay probabilidad de nuevos linajes y
variantes lo que vemos en la inequidad
todavía patente en las vacunas es que
hay mucha población no vacunada en donde
emergen los linajes como estos sub
linajes de lo micro y en la población
implante también se podrían generar de
asociaciones del virus para crear nuevas
variantes por eso la vacunación se hace
y la inmunidad colectiva no cuando se va
un país o un porcentaje es cuando se va
con el planeta incluyendo desde los 0
hasta los más de 100 años toda la
población para que logramos inmunidad
colectiva probablemente con otra
segunda generación de vacunas pero
debemos vacunarnos todos doctores le
creo preguntar por qué tanta reticencia
entre los padres y responsables de los
menores de edad para no vacunar los
el desenlace al no ser la mortalidad
digamos que se pierde el miedo el apego
que es enseñar que los niños se pueden
enfermar sobre todo niños con
comorbilidades de enfermedades cardíacas
pulmonares renales que afectan esa
población el código puede ser una
enfermedad que puede ser fatal pero
también entender que los niños pudieran
llevar un nuevo linaje de virus a
personas susceptibles a sus hogares
es importante que nos vacunemos no
solamente para evitar la enfermedad sino
en alguna forma de tratar de cortar esa
cadena de transmisión para hacer hogares
más seguros y es creo que un poco más de
falta de pago ya que reticencia de los
padres todos queremos proteger a
nuestros hijos adoptar una última
pregunta también para terminar y
habíamos hemos mencionado de que los
niños parecen desarrollar cuadros menos
graves de la enfermedad
queríamos preguntarle si se sabe por qué
sucede esto
si digamos hay varios aspectos uno son
los receptores de los virus que son
mucho más
abundantes en la población adulta eso
hace que el virus se desarrolle menos en
los órganos en los niños que en los
adultos
que también la respuesta inmunológica
que se hace hacia este tipo de unidos
hay algún tipo de inmunidad cruzada que
pudiera ser que se desarrolla menos la
enfermedad sin embargo en los niños
sobre todo en personas niños que tienen
afectación cardiaca o pulmonar esta
enfermedad ha tenido un desenlace no
favorable y que es inmunoprevenible que
podemos evitar esa mortalidad en los
niños la enfermedad no es grave pero no
es que no sea seria en algún grupo de
personas y es muy importante en personas
debilitadas tenemos que vacunarnos todos
adultos adultos mayores hombres mujeres
y sobre todo los niños y niñas para
evitar la reemergencia de nuevos linajes
y que podamos apaciguar este virus de
una vez por todas pues el toro
muchísimas gracias como siempre por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros
acompañándonos todas las mañanas de
leones en directo américa de francés de
4 también en mar muchísimas gracias nos
vemos con más salud pasamos a saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado